i think it was you matt that was talking
i think yesterday about having a curated
reality i think you mentioned truman
show that's a great comparison yeah i
like content creator i kind of stumbled
on this thing yesterday that uh
another way of looking at the corporate
media is that they're
reality curators
and that's a lot of what they do they
don't necessarily lie and well they do
plenty of lying but most of the time
they're not like pretending something
happened when it didn't really happen
again they do that but but more often
the bias comes from deciding what to
tell us about what bits of reality to
bring to our attention and um and yeah i
think about that scene in uh in in the
truman show which i brought up
when uh the director was asked like why
hasn't truman ever
questioned his reality and uh the
director said well we we accept uh the
reality of the world that we're
presented um and and
there's a lot of truth to that that you
just kind of accepted also that word
presented is important because that's
how most of us it's not that we're like
encountering reality or discovering it
we kind of sit back and we stare at our
screens all day and we have reality
presented to us we have people usually
corporate media telling us well this is
reality this is what's true but it's all
it's all curated based on what they want
us to believe and so waukesha for
example is a good example of something
that that doesn't fit into the reality
that they want us to understand so that
doesn't make it in they don't curate
that for us well they very simply just
say an suv
you know hit people an accident caused
by an suv but i'll point out too just a
side note on the truman show thing
uh it's a good point we don't we don't
question the result reality presented in
the truman show he starts to notice
things like he goes into a building and
there's no elevator it's a set but if if
he was born there and his whole life was
seeing that kind of stuff he'd never
question it he'd be like oh another
studio set behind an elevator i see him
all the time yeah well there's a reason
they call it programming and i think
there's something to say about echo
chambers and the carefully curated
algorithms that give us information that
of course enforce a particular viewpoint
and the power that big tech social media
has they have the will to impose
people's perceptions and ideas and there
should definitely be a bigger discussion
about this but earlier tim i think you
said something that definitely uh is
important to talk about is that it's not
really left and right it's it's whether
you believe in authoritarianism or if
you believe in freedom i think that's
the true kind of bigger political
compass that people should be talking
about that people should be
understanding and when it comes to even
calling them content creators i think
that's given them too much credit
because they're not creating content
they're regurgitating repeating
corporatist talking points that of
course special interests feed them and
they just regurgitate it back to the
general public we know but content
creator is meant to irk them yes maybe
corporate content regurgitator or a
creator i don't know but look
when it comes to the different political
compasses you know idea of like the
bubble the blue pill false reality
within the corporate press
i i don't think that adequately explains
you know
the phenomena we're experiencing with
the culture work because i've i've
thought about that maybe it's just the
libertarian spectrum
of course we all agree you know if i'm
like oh no brent's really cool and he
made this a comic book called snow white
zombie apocalypse that i've helped
kickstart a couple times i think it's
fantastic really really great art cool
story it's not super political or
anything but you know we were having a
discussion about kyle rittenhouse and
he's very much in the corporate press
version of what cal right now was doing
he was posting on facebook saying the
prosecution's case is super strong i was
surprised he was repeating the
prosecution's talking points you'd
probably hear on msnbc or things like
that and we were talking about it you
know he said uh we got to this point
where he said something i was talking
about the prison system it being broken
anyway and i don't understand why he
would be on the side of the state in
this regard and he was like the state is
illegitimate and i was like okay well
hold on in there a minute i was like we
can agree on almost everything we come
to this point where we're like
when you say the state is illegitimate
i'll be a bit facetious and say we agree
on that and what i mean is like we
disregard the establishment the
authority and the lies and the
manipulation but when you're in this
different version of reality we don't we
we can't work together towards like
solving any problem
because his version of reality is you
know kyle rittenhouse was a violent
reactionary who showed up to to hurt
protesters and i'm like but that's just
not true
if you live in the in the world of the
corporate press it doesn't matter if you
think the state is illegitimate and
you're an anarchist
you live in a false reality where your
motivations are fueled by incorrect
information leading to leading you to
cheer for the state like like he was
doing so i mean that with with all due
respect you know i i think he's a cool
dude but there we we very seriously
disagree on what is even true yeah it's
gonna as curation like you were saying
these companies basically curating what
we see defects when people they're going
to be able to be like they're going to
show you something that's not real and
they're going to tell you it's real and
then they're going to be able to be like
we wash our hands of it we received it
we checked it out it looked real to us
we were just reporting on what we
thought was real and then people are
going to be seeding all these deep fakes
that are like yep it might even be the
news organizations that create the
d-picks we find later but then they're
just telling us they didn't know they
were fake spider-man
spider-man 3. what about it sam raimi's
yeah so you got the dancing one yes okay
yes so um uh i bring this up because it
was on tv and i happened to have seen it
but there's a really there's a scene
where eddie barack is the character who
wants to be a staff photographer peter
parker has been a freelance photographer
there for years so eddie brock is
sucking up to jameson who's the the
editor-in-chief or the
whatever position he has
and he says whoever gets me a photo of
spider-man with his hand in the cookie
jar gets the job so what does brock do
he photoshops an image of spider-man
committing a crime they run another
front page he gets hired they later find
out they have to retract i think it's a
stretch you know for you know if
in real life they probably wouldn't
retract they just feel like like you
said well we were reporting the truth at
the time so there you go
but uh as much as it's a silly fictional
example of this i bring it up because
that's what happens
you have quote unquote journalists who
are like i need to move up in this
company i need to get traffic you know
there are a lot of companies that pay
their writers based on how much how many
clicks they get oh wow like this is this
is gawker gawker was notorious for like
get a bunch of views you get you get
paid more money a lot of right wing
websites do the exact same thing what
are you gonna get you're gonna get
people trying to write as as click-baity
sensational stuff as they can and
eventually you'll find people who here's
a good example you ever see the movie
nightcrawler yeah amazing movie jake
gyllenhaal and he's a sociopath trying
to find a way to make money and he
stumbles upon late night crawling it's
when you go out in the middle of the
night and track down crimes
fires crashes hurt people and things
like that and he begins actually staging
like he actually i don't want to ruin
the movie because it's so good but he's
a nasty sociopath who stages some of
these photos
you get these people in media then you
give them the virtue signal ability to
like pretend to be political and they
will run with it now they've got a
safety net a barrier to where they can
make things up write garbled nonsense to
get massive clicks make money and
they're protected when they do it why
because they're on the right side of
history so they say
they're not just protected their
competition is eliminated and of course
fact checked into oblivion and down
ranked in the algorithm where you can't
even see them even if you're subscribed
to them i think it was buzzfeed that had
an infographic at their office studio
showing the articles that are getting
the most amount of shares and a live
number update graphic showing everyone
working there what's what's getting the
clicks what's not getting the clicks and
once you kind of involve yourself into
pleasing the algorithm you're involved
in pleasing of course the agenda of the
people who are creating the algorithm
who's creating the algorithm who's
running the algorithms what's the
response and result of these algorithms
well i think superficially we could look
at it and see there's a lot of
depression there's a lot more suicide
there's a lot more self-hate there's a
lot of other psychological issues that
are encroaching and becoming more of a
problem every single day and when we
look at these algorithms they rule our
lives because they rule perceptions and
understandings and once you have control
of that in my opinion you have control
of everything and that's why the world
is in one factor so messed up as it is
right now because of this tightly
controlled small viewpoint that that
they're doing everything in their power
to make sure that you don't see outside
of it and when you do you see that it's
full of crap yeah absolutely and now one
of the things that i was noticing today
was that twitter i know we were talking
yesterday about how their new ceo might
be worse than the old one it turns out
that this is definitely gonna be the
case because one of the things that
they're gonna do is like remove the
right of these independent journalists
post
material that's not approved right so
it's going to be a serious issue as far
as journal actual journalism because i
really feel like the written house trial
was such a triumph for places like the
daily caller people who right-wing
journalists who are actually on the
ground and like unbiased journalists who
really went out there and did the work
so i feel like twitter has really
twisted it yeah dorsey is not the demon
that he had been made out to be he was
he was like has five percent of twitter
and was like basically holding on for
dear life trying to make it
something fault
the day he leaves and the new ceos like
here's what real authority is
yeah maybe so i think uh i i think the
challenge we face at least to kind of
like wrap up this portion of like the
content curators and the the corporate
press and all that stuff
it's it's getting through to people
you know it's it's finding that regular
person who maybe doesn't pay attention
and
being able to pitch them on their own
intrinsic value life liberty and
happiness but they have to want it
so when you have people who just say
look man i just want to fit in they're
going to walk right to you know uh
to
brian stelter or whatever you know other
content creators at cnn and just say
tell me what to think and i'll think it
because i just want to fit in
so how do we convince people
be your own person
stand up for yourself
i don't know maybe you can't maybe
what's really happening is a sorting
algorithm of people who just want to
follow and people who want to be
independent and i think the other really
what we're talking about the real
division is uh
we're now living in a in a country where
there's basically
two different at least two different
realities that we're living in
and uh two different universes really so
when we when people talk about are we
headed towards a civil war that sort of
thing i think we're not just because
for a civil war you need a you need like
a geographic divide which which there
isn't as much right now as there was in
uh in in 1861 i would say but i do think
that we're more divided than we were in
the civil war um the conditions are
there in that sense because we just when
you when you get a hundred americans
into a room from all over the country
and you start talking to them um you'll
find that they don't they're they have
absolutely nothing in common at all at
no level like you talk to them about
their fundamental priorities and values
what things do they care about the most
all that kind of stuff you're gonna find
that um there is almost no common thread
bringing them all together no no
commonality no nothing uniting us and it
has to be something some uniting
principle and there is it's uh it's two
different moral frameworks at the end of
the day right you have the the uh
christian judeo-christian moral
framework and then you have this new
locust moral framework which is
completely removed from it so one of the
ways i explain it to people is uh bill
maher's a great example clearly a person
who was raised on christian moral values
even though he's an atheist so he
believes in free speech he believes in
innocent until proven guilty concepts
that are in the bible so in america a
lot of our foundational rights
inalienable rights granted by god that
was the perception of the founding
fathers even people who were growing up
in the 80s 90s and becoming prominent
might not believe in any of that stuff
but they hold those moral frameworks
still within them from their the
traditions that they were handed they
were given but now you have a new moral
framework completely removed from all
those values they don't believe in the
right of the innocent until proven
guilty you know they're they're
something completely separate if they
even have a moral framework i do want to
mention though
i disagree with you on the need for a
geographical divide
that's uh um that's an american
perspective on civil war if you look at
a lot of other countries spanish civil
war is a really good example they didn't
have a geographical geographical divide
in the same way they had cities versus
the rural areas rural nationalists and
urban communists so i believe that's
what it was i believe the communists
were centered around cities i could be
wrong but it was it was essentially
fascists and communists and if you look
at the initial battle maps where the
ideology started getting power it was
splotchy it was like the left-wing group
was here then it was over here and they
were not united or connected in any way
so we actually that we do have in the
united states but in america the civil
war here was based on you know we have
each individual state siding on a
specific you know states rights slavery
versus you know more united federalist
power which ultimately resulted in
states breaking apart and then the
interesting thing i think it was uh
texas was like we have no choice because
we're surrounded by southern states who
hold this all these values we we
wouldn't be able to be on the side
anyway so in that sense i i think
there's a there's a you know you're sort
of correct
yeah i sort of agree with you that's a
good point so i guess i would go to my
my other my other reason why i don't
think there's actually a civil war is
that uh
nobody wants to leave their air
conditioning and their tv for very long
like we all we all there's just there's
not the there's not the wherewithal the
will for that sort of thing but i i but
i still fun i still disagree um
you know are you familiar with the
fourth turning the strassa generational
theory stuff
no so they say it's like every 80 years
there's a conflict we had the american
revolution eight years later the civil
war eight years later you know world war
ii
now it's 80 years later and you know
what are we expecting to see in this
fourth turning period there's four
separate you know 20-year periods i'm
not saying that's definitively true but
i certainly think we're headed towards a
period of great strife and i think that
one of the other challenges with civil
war is that people believe
that they they look to history to get
example of what war is
and so we look back at the american
civil war and see people fighting we
look back at world war ii and people are
running through the fields but we're in
the era of social media manipulation and
it's fourth and fifth generational
warfare so they're using propaganda
using corporate press they're using
censorship using economic control
they don't need to point a weapon at you
to convince you to do something if they
can take away your ability to
communicate with anyone else or make you
think that a weapon's being pointed at
you even though it's not or you're going
to face some repercussions if you commit
wrong think and matt you made a very
good point we are very comfortable we
are very blessed we are very lucky you
notice that especially if you travel the
world and you compare our lifestyles to
how everyone else is living but that is
rapidly changing right now especially
with the economic turmoil that's being
created by the centralization of
economic forces by the federal
government by the federal reserve that i
believe deliberately is trying to create
havoc on the world economic market that
is creating not only inflation
shrink-flation meat-flation but just the
utter devaluation of the u.s dollar and
i think soon america will have to live
like the rest of the world i think there
will be a shock and in that shock in
that kind of
larger transfer of wealth that has been
happening since the beginning of this
pandemic i do think there's a potential
for conflict i hope it doesn't happen
i'm not saying it is going to happen but
i think there is a window where that
potential opens especially with the
economic havoc coming our way which i
believe is deliberately being pushed on
by a lot of centralized big powerful
players thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you